Thank You bricks it has been long it's
been painful and it's been divisive but
this is a great deal for the UK that was
the message from the UK's Prime Minister
Boris Johnson speaking right now in
Brussels after he and other leaders from
the European Union and the United
Kingdom said that they had effectively
reached a tentative agreement on brexit
let's bring in Jonah Hall he's joining
us from Brussels the hard work though
starts now some might say Jonah because
this still needs to be ratified by the
EU Parliament and the UK Parliament
absolutely and and most of the questions
put to Boris Johnson there made that
point and challenged him on quite why he
was so confident that it would get
through the UK Parliament what would
happen if it didn't would he ask for a
delay as he is required to under law
sort of in vintage Johnson press
conference performance there as we've
come to expect he didn't answer really
any of the questions put to him instead
repeating what is now a mantra that he
is confident that MPs will vote for this
deal this is our chance to honor the
Democratic mandate of the referendum and
get 4x it down it's a great deal for the
UK and a great deal for the EU he said
but yes he will be as certain as
everybody else that what happens here
tonight in Brussels among EU leaders is
really just the first stumbling profit
bloc and by no means the most difficult
one the most difficult one will be in
the House of Commons even the EU
Parliament may delay things beyond
October the 31st wishing to have more
time to scrutinize the detail but it
could fall entirely on Saturday when
there is this meaningful vote scheduled
in London and the numbers just don't
stack up obviously in Boris Johnson's
favors he'd favour he took the whip away
from 21 of his own MPs he's got a a
majority of - 45 the DUP who
traditionally have supported him say
they're not going to vote for it those
on the right of his party who
traditionally have taken their cue from
the DUP may or may not vote for it
labour won't vote for it though some
Labour MPs might and it remains unclear
fight what happens
except that he is bound by law now that
been act this backbench piece of
legislation to ask for a delay if it
fails and we have to see what the EU
leaders have to say that yeah and we
also did hear from EU leaders a little
earlier right before Boris Johnson was
speaking and they seem to express relief
that this deal has been reached yes I
mean it's been an awful long road and
ordeal and torturous process three and a
half years since the brexit vote three
years of negotiating trying to get to
this point with several false starts
along the way there is an enormous sense
of relief that's very evident among the
leaders just a week ago they didn't
think they'd be sitting here with a new
deal and one that really both sides
feels relatively pleased about there is
a sense of expectation now that you know
let's send this to the parliaments and
get this thing done but of course
nobody's in any doubt about the
difficulties that I've just outlined the
numbers that are there the big question
is what happens if it doesn't work will
there be a delay but to give you a sense
of the sort of expectation in the room
here was Donald Tusk the President of
the Council giving his view on what has
happened the reality is that today you
have a deal
which allows us to avoid chaos and an
atmosphere of conflict between the eu27
and the United Kingdom on a more
personal note what I feel today is
frankly speaking sadness because in my
heart I will always be remainder and I
hope that if our British friends decides
to return one day
our dole our door will always be open
well that sense of regret expressed by
Donald to us they're repeated by Michele
Barnea the e use negotiated by so
implored young kabylie or vodka the
Irish teacher of all on that stage
together but the sense is that here we
are here we are the first stumbling
block over let's get on with Briggs it's
now the summit conclusions are out this
is only a political nod by the leaders
endorsing or
is a draft framework of a deal it now
has to be ratified by the parliaments
the aim in the draft summit conclusions
was to say let's get it done by the 1st
of November that really is down to what
happens in London on Saturday okay Jonah
hall thank you